today we are going to be making this  cheddar bacon loaded baked potato soup  it's the ultimate comfort food so let's  do it so you're going to start by  cooking a pound of bacon and removing it  from the pot you're then going to add  garlic scallion and flour into your pot  to build a roux before pouring in some  chicken broth heavy cream milk and  spices to taste then you're going to  toss in your potatoes and let that cook  Slow and Low until your potatoes are  nice and soft go ahead and stir in two  cups of cheese and you're going to let  that simmer add in some more bacon and  scallions and like I like to serve mine  with some sour cream on top a little bit  of bacon cheddar and just load it all up  try this recipe out and let me know what  you think